[Applause]
this is becoming increasingly
clear that your brother Napoleon
bonapart with his show of military might
is acting as an
outlaw and this is a ridiculous and
poorly executed takeover a power hungry
upstart enough enough there is any
question here I will
answer
you have violated the
[Applause]
Constitution
right we are being terrorized by
deputies armed with daggers and these
Mad Men have outl themselves for their
attempt on the liberty of this country
they're trying to kill me they're try to
kill him
open
I will kill my brother if he betrays the
freedom of the French
people get
[Applause]
out
good Lu
brother stand
aside
I